Ariana Grande pens an emotional note  thanking fans after wrapping her  European tour  [Music]  it's almost been one month since the  tragic bombing at Ariana's concert in  Manchester England took the lives of 22  people and left more than 100 injured  the 23 year old singer took to social  media Sunday to show her appreciation to  fans for their support while she  finished out the European leg of her  dangerous woman tour writing in part  spending this time with you this month  has been so very healing and special  thank you for bringing your absolute  brightest most passionate contagious  energy to these shows and for wiping my  tears away  [Music]  arianna also shared two videos from her  show and turn italy thanking her band in  the caption as well quote you are so  incredible endlessly grateful for you  guys  [Music]